(Tywin): Rhaegar Targaryen
lay dead on the banks of the Trident,
his royal army shattered and in retreat.
The days of the dragon kings
were clearly numbered.
Until that moment, it would have been
foolish to commit Casterly Rock
to either the Crown or the rebellion.
What would our family have to gain
in supporting a raving madman?
Or in entering a crusade to put
Robert Baratheon on the Iron Throne?
But chaos benefits no one.
It was time for House Lannister
to do what it could
to ensure a return of peace and prosperity
to the land.
I, Tywin Lannister,
brought 10,000 Lannister troops
to the gates of King's Landing,
in order to bring the bloodshed
to a quick and decisive conclusion.
King Aerys had been
sending ravens for months,
begging for my support to end the uprising.
In a way, his pleas had been answered.
As I had suspected, Aerys opened
the city gates and welcomed my men.
Our plan was clear -
crush Aerys' remaining bannermen
and remove the remnants
of the royal family
as quickly and efficiently as possible.
Any alternative meant years of further war
and a fragmented Seven Kingdoms.
Our means were bloody,
but the results speak for themselves.
As for Aerys, it is true
he met his fate at the hands of my son.
Aerys had kept Jaime close
during the rebellion,
thinking himself clever
in keeping my son as a hostage
should I decide to pledge support
to the rebel cause.
This proved to be his greatest mistake,
for, when the time came,
Jaime did his duty as a Lannister...
and drove his sword
into the Mad King's back.
With that,
Robert Baratheon's crown was secured.
The new king recognized our role
in his ascension to the throne,
just as he recognized how useful
the might and riches
of Casterly Rock would be...
if he wanted to keep it.
To that end,
I offered my daughter Cersei as his queen.
Had Aerys not spurned
this same offer years earlier...
perhaps things would have
worked out differently.
With Robert and Cersei crowned
as king and queen of the Seven Kingdoms,
it was a new day.
The dragon was vanquished
and the Seven Kingdoms
would thereafter belong to the Stag.
And the Lion.